she's busted a cap in the Kingpin dated
Daredevil and hunted Hawkeye here's what
you need to know about the upcoming
Marvel series Ekko as the conflicted
Hero at the center of it all in the last
episode of Hawkeye we see Maya Lopez
declare war on Wilson Fisk the infamous
Crim Lord and Maya's adoptive Uncle so
where will the echo series pick up we
know Maya will leave New York City and
head back to her hometown to reconnect
with her family and Native American
Heritage speaking with kider Marvel
produc producer Steven brousard delved a
bit deeper into the show's tone saying
it's a very different tonal sort of
thing it feels very grounded it feels
very spiritual in ways that feel fresh
for us he also spoke about the setting
of the series explaining that it takes
place in rural Oklahoma we also know the
series will focus on events in Maya's
childhood plus we'll see the effects of
her relationship with the Kingpin play
out across the series at an October 2023
press event director and executive
producer Sydney Freeland said the show
is is going to put an emphasis on trauma
and how the characters cope with it
driving home the personal Stakes
Freeland went on to say it's not the
fate of the universe at stake this is
the fate of family Alara Cox is of
course reprising her role as Maya Lopez
in the spin-off series what's especially
wild is that Hawkeye was Cox's first
ever acting role she also has the
distinction of being the first Native
American hero and the second de
superhero in the MCU of course C won't
be the only Hawkeye character coming
back Vincent D will be returning as the
murderous Wilson Fisk of Daredevil Fame
we can also expect the return of Z
mclaran who played Maya's loving father
they'll be joined by another character
who's instantly recognizable to Marvel
fans Charlie Cox is returning as Matt
Murdoch AKA Daredevil rounding out the
cast Ekko is shining the spotlight on
some serious indigenous Talent we've got
Graham green Charles K Spencer tantu
Cardinal Dey Jacobs and Cody lightning
rumors have suggested that we might also
see a plotline involving Kristen
Ritter's Jessica Jones but that remains
speculation for now when it comes to
behind the scenes Talent Ekko boasts
some pretty impressive filmmakers
serving as headwriter we've got Mari and
dare who's worked on high-profile series
like the act shantaram and better coral
on the directing side of things the
episodes will be helmed by indigenous
directors Sydney Freeland and Katrina
McKenzie McKenzie has worked on TV
series such as The Walking Dead chilling
Adventures of Sabrina and Supernatural
whereas Freeland is directed Epis epodes
of reservation dogs Star Trek strange
new worlds and Rutherford fools these
creatives are taking echo in important
new directions such as switching Maya
Lopez from a member of the cheyen tribe
to a member of the chu Tor tribe along
with that they're diving deep into the
chu Tor culture striving to make a
series that's as accurate as possible we
also know that they're switching at
Maya's Powers with freelance saying that
that same October 2023 press event her
power in the comic book is that she can
copy anything any movement any whatever
it's it's kind of lame I will say that
is not her power I'll just kind of leave
it at that for the longest time Marvel
has stayed away from getting two Edy in
the MCU their movies are All PG-13 and
their TV shows are all familyfriendly
however in recent years the MCU has been
putting the boundaries a bit Guardians
of the Galaxy volume 3 dropped the mcu's
first death bomb open the door Marvel
brass has promised that Deadpool 3 will
be rated R and now echko will be the
first MCU TV show with the TV MA rating
speaking about this gritty new tone at
the October 2023 press event director
and executive producer Sydney Freeland
said we wanted very very adamantly to
show that these are people on our show
they bleed they die they get killed and
there are real world consequences in
other words it looks like Ekko will be
following more in the criter footsteps
of Netflix's Daredevil as opposed to the
Disney Plus show Hawkeye by this point
we've all gotten used to the fact that
MCU projects all tie into each other
every installment whether it be on
Disney new Plus or the big screen
contributes to the larger hole and helps
push the overall Saga along even as it
tells its own story The Hawai series
first introduced Ekko and set her up for
her own series and the big question now
is how Ekko will feed back into the
ongoing saga of the MCU as it turns out
Ekko might somewhat break from the
Marvel tradition and tell a story that's
much more self-contained than we've all
grown accustomed to Marvel Studios is
launching a new initiative called Marvel
Spotlight that will highlight stories
that don't ask viewers to be perfectly
caught up with all the MCU law Ekko will
be the first show Branded as part of
Marvel Spotlight the MCU like the Marvel
Comics that came before it has
admittedly gotten a little we down by
its own interconnected law back in the
early 1970s Marvel Comics also dealt
with this issue by creating a Marvel
Spotlight series that focused on telling
Standalone Stories the MCU is really
just catching up to Marvel's past here
Ekko may be more or less Standalone but
the show is still part of the MCU so
even even though you don't need to watch
every other piece of Marvel content to
follow what's happening Eko still has a
place in the overall MCU timeline that
timeline has gotten a bit harder to
follow in recent years and tends to
leave newcomers to the universe saying
what is this place but luckily it's not
hard to find where Echo fits in it which
might be exactly why Marvel picked this
to be the first Marvel Spotlight show
Ekko was again first introduced in
Hawkeye as a skilled leader and brutal
fighter she had a bit of a vendetta
against Clint Barton because of his
actions as Ronin but the two of them
settled their differences and now ekko's
own show will pick up sometime shortly
after the events of Hawkeye that means
Ekko takes place well after the blip and
it's happening at more or less the same
time as other phase 5 MCU shows and
movies since Ekko is supposed to be more
self-contained in other Marvel stories
you probably won't hear all that much
about the blip and you definitely won't
need to know what the other in Universe
Heroes like Captain Marvel are up to
music has a big role to play in any show
but it's going to be especially
important animportant for EO other
Marvel projects both inside and outside
of the MCU have made a splash for their
soundtracks in the past and a strong one
could really help Ekko make a big splash
luckily the series scor is in good hands
Ekko landed one of the most talented
young composers in the business
25-year-old Mar wui is best known for
his work on the Hulu series reservation
darks but he's also worked on
featurelength films like War Pony and
he's released a number of his own albums
while yui will be bringing that
experience to his work on Echo and will
also be bringing his own perspective as
a member of the agala Lakota tribe in
South Dakota Ekko herself is Native
American and the TV show will Explore
her relationship to her family and her
native identity because of that wui
might be the perfect person to have been
tapped as composer for the series the
point of the new Marvel Spotlight Banner
is to create MCU content that's more
welcoming to newcomers than the mainline
shows and movies but if you're really
excited to dive into eeko you might want
to spend some time catching up on the
bits of MCU history that are most likely
to tie into the show Hawkeye is an
obvious one you'll get to see ekko's
very first MCU appearance and get some
deeper insight into what she was doing
just before the start of her own series
but if you're a real Marvel completist
you might want to catch up with some of
the other characters who are going to
appear in Echo the first trailer for the
show made it clear that Wilson Fisk is
going to have a fairly large role to
play you and
I are the same he was first introduced
in the Netflix Daredevil Series so
watching that will get you up to speed
on its history and help you prepare for
the inevitable appearance of Charlie Cox
as Daredevil hawy is available to stream
on Disney plus the Netflix daredevil
show has also made its way to Disney
plus basically Disney plus is your
One-Stop shop for everything that's
related to eeko so you can binge the
full backstory before you binge the
brand new series plenty of fans first
met Ekko when Hawkeye aired in
2021 but comic book fans have known her
for more than two decades Ekko was first
introduced in Daredevil Volume 2 issue
99 and was initially introduced as an
antagonist chasing down our hero she
squared off against Daredevil because
she mistakenly believed that he was the
man who killed her father she went on to
join the new Avengers and get caught up
in all sorts of Marvel Shenanigans like
World War Hulk and secret Invasion the
MCU version of Ekko has already deviated
from the comic book Cannon pretty
significantly it already seems safe to
say that Ekko won't be an adaptation of
any particular storyline from the comics
though it might draw some inspiration
from ekko's earlier Marvel history in
the comics Fisk killed ekko's father
himself but it's too early to tell if
that particular traumatic event will
work its way into the new Disney Plus
show it seems that almost anywhere the
Kingpin goes Daredevil is sure to follow
the hero actually didn't appear in
Hawkeye but now thanks to Spider-Man no
way home and She-Hulk we know that he's
officially in the MCU I'm here he's set
to come back once again for echo which
means we could see him coming face to
face with the Kingpin for the first time
since the Netflix Daredevil series ended
there aren't any solid details about
Daredevil's presence in Ekko just yet
for all we know he could have next to
nothing to do with the plot but assuming
the show is taking some cues from the
comics it could also be a central part
of ekko's story in the comics the two
fought each other multiple times before
Ekko realized that the Kingpin had
manipulated her which led to her paying
him back by blinding him with a gunshot
sometimes family doesn't see I
to that part of the story already played
out in Hawkeye but the next part of
ekko's relationship with Daredevil could
still happen after putting their
fighting days behind them in the comics
the two actually fell in love their
relationship on the page has always been
Frau with tension romance is never easy
for superheroes but they've always been
able to rely on each other in times of
need maybe we'll get to see a new take
on that romantic relationship in Echo
ever since One Division first premiered
in early 2021 Marvel has followed the
same exact formula for its Disney Plus
shows instead of releasing every episode
at once they've been going the
Mandalorian route releasing one episode
per week however that's going to change
with echo which will be using the binge
model yep all five episodes will be
available to stream on the same day in
fact Ekko will hit Disney plus and Hulu
at the same time Ekko was originally
meant to premiere on November 29th but
with Marvel wanting to make sure their
products were in tiptop shape coupled
with the sagaa and wga Strikes the
studio reshuffled its TV schedule now
Ekko will be hitting Disney plus and
Hulu on January 10th 2024 see you
[Music]
there